Hey guys,
what's up?
Welcome to answer them.
My name is [inaudible] and I'm an editor
for a stout which is the largest Dutch
web luck in the world today and once
again joined by a man and no longer
needs any introduction.
Dr Jordan Peterson.
How are you doing?
Thanks for sitting down with us again.
Nice to see you again.
Uh,
the last time we sat down for a talk in
our studio in two weeks.
That will be exactly one year ago.
And then with us and it was the first
time you responded on video to the
aftermath of the,
of the getting human interview.
And we also did a discussion of my
distillation into five points of your
philosophy for the people at home for
the people watching.
You can find a link in the description
if you want to,
if you want to check it out today.
I again want to do five things and I'm
going to run through it.
And before we start,
we're going to do a year review of 2018
in which I just want to hear how you
look back on last year.
What you've been through,
what,
what were the defining experiences and
then we're going to discuss how in
identity politics,
a collective narrative substitutes the
individual experience,
and then we're going to leave the
physical world and go metaphysical.
We're going to discuss the movie
gladiator and why it is so ingrained in
my generation psyche more so than any
other movie of it,
and then we're going to discuss how to
become sorry,
out to become something approximating
the male archetype or we don't to focus
especially on the human notion of
individuation and delve into that.
And five and final point,
we're going to discuss the idea,
the idea that the artist is a portal
between the dream world and the
collective unconscious on one hand and
consciousness.
On the other hand,
I wonder if we should reverse the order
of the fourth and fifth.
So start with art and then
individuation.
Alright,
I can do that.
Noted.
Yeah,
I think that'll make a better flow.
Alright,
we'll do that.
Well,
without further ado,
let's delve into it year review.
I've always wanted to do that.
I'm sorry,
2018.
What were your,
what were the defining experiences for
you?
How do you look back on it?
You visited over 100 cities.
One on.
I can't even name 100 cities,
so that's impressive.
Well,
I did visit a couple of points so but I
think it was 115 lectures and so
100 cities.
The defining features of it.
Well,
back in January,
that's when my book came out and it was
at that point that I started to
thoroughly realized that there was
enough of a market for what it was that
I was talking about to risk
experimenting with large scale venues
and I,
I found that out
because of my experience to experience
this year before I had done a series of
biblical lectures on Genesis and I
rented a theater in Toronto more out of
curiosity than a good sense,
let's say to see if there might be an
audience for such a thing.
And the theater held about 500 people
and I get 50 lectures over the course of
a couple of months and every.
It's sold out every time so that.
Well,
that was,
you might call that a data point was
interesting because it wasn't obvious
that a discussion of something as Arcane
and archaic and hypothetically outdated
as the book of Genesis would draw an
audience and the audience was also
primarily composed of the people who you
would least likely to come and attend to
such a thing.
And that was mostly men and they held
you in like a rockstar.
It was like plus when you entered stage
yet I.
well,
I guess it's a strange thing to see
actually,
that's for sure.
Especially in the context of the
discussions,
you know,
so.
So then,
well then I went to London.
I think I've got the itinerary,
the timeline correct.
I might have mixed up except for a
couple of things,
but I went to London to talk about the
launch of my book because it was
published their first and I think it was
published on January 23rd,
so that's almost a year behind us now as
well.
And the publishers,
they're wanting to arrange a public talk
and so they first read it,
that 300 seat auditorium theater and
it's sold out instantly and so they
moved it to a thousand seats,
if I remember correctly.
And then to a very large venue of the
Apollo,
I think that was in January.
Although as I said,
I'm not exactly certain that might have
followed my.
Yeah,
I think that's right.
So,
so that was extremely interesting as
well.
And that went very well.
And uh,
my.
After I came back from London,
my daughter and I decided to try to do
the same thing in La at the orpheum.
So we contacted them and of course they
were very skeptical and they had every
right to be because they didn't know who
I was and I wasn't represented by any
organization
or if you have sold out to,
these are all theaters of about 2,500
pasty.
So they're fairly large scale.
Well,
at the same time,
around the same time,
interestingly enough,
I was contacted by an organization in La
called CAA creative artists agency.
And it's the largest,
um,
it's the largest agency of its type and
I suppose the most prestigious,
I was negotiating with another one at
the same time or as an alternative,
but they contacted me more or less out
of the blue it said that they would like
to represent me and they were associated
with live nation,
which does theatrical bookings for
performers of all sorts all over the
world.
And so things just fell into place.
Christie,
oddly enough,
my daughter Mckenna pushed very hard for
my,
uh,
my enrollment with Ca.
She thought after multiple conversations
with them that they were very competent,
which they have turned out to be.
And so things just started to roll from
there.
And we,
we hit major cities,
the major markets first in the United
States.
And that went very successfully.
And so we extended that to Canada and
then into smaller markets.
US and
lectures,
I think about a hundred of them sold out
completely.
The other ones did well sometimes those,
we're in markets that I returned to a
few months previously.
So.
So those are highlights.
I mean,
the highlight though really is the fact
that the lecture series has been so
positive,
you know,
the events are unbelievably causative.
They're not political.
I wouldn't say they're fundamentally
psychological.
They concentrate on individual
development.
I speak about politics from time to
time,
but more from a psychological
perspective,
outlining the temperamental reasons why
people might lean to the left or to the
right and emphasizing the necessity of
both perspectives,
let's say,
and,
and the what med necessity of them
engaging in continual dialogue in order
to keep the ship of state sailing,
sailing upright and,
and,
and oriented towards the proper
destination and say,
what else?
Well,
at the same time it was still a
tremendous amount of media attention,
often negative,
sometimes positive.
Um,
a lot of contentious interviews with
journalists.
Uh,
interestingly enough,
the more contentious interviews like the
Kathy Newman interview,
but more recently an interview I did
with Gq
tend to attract the most attention on
youtube.
I'm also the most stressful and
difficult of interviews and something
that,
for the sake of my own psychological
stability,
should probably be somewhat avoided.
Takes me about three days to recover
from an interview like that,
and then also the overwhelming success
of the book,
which has now been,
we have contracts in place to translate
12 rules for life into 50 languages,
which pretty much does all the languages
where there's reasonable publication
market and um,
it's so two and a half million copies
and in hardcover trade paperback,
primarily hardcover.
That also includes ebooks and kindle
downloads and that sort of thing.
The English language world and maybe
another half a million in the countries
where translations have appeared.
Those so far I would say.
So there's a huge market for unpacking
old stories.
Well,
apparently there's a huge market and
there's a huge market.
More importantly,
I would say for a discussion that
centers on the relationship between
responsibility and meaning,
which is also something that I'm working
on delineating in my next book,
which I'm writing right now.
In fact,
I was writing it just reading,
uh,
a central chapter,
chapter six,
which is called a notice.
That opportunity lurks where
responsibility has been abandoned.
And one of the things I noticed in the
lectures is that whenever I talk about
the relationship between responsibility
and meaning,
the lecture hall always goes dead silent
and that's very significant,
especially because it's happened more
than 100 times and I really be watching
this.
So I read that most specifically that
there's a void in our culture,
I think produced by nonstop discussion
of rights and privileges and that void
has to do with the necessity for the
counterbalancing discussion,
which is a discussion of responsibility.
Thing is is the conservative people tend
to
market responsibility as duty,
right?
Sort of as should or should not often,
should not sometimes should.
And that's perfectly reasonable because
we have duties and they're necessary
because we're social creatures and we
have to engage in reciprocal
interactions with others,
but it still misses the point.
A point which has also missed by people
on the left who were always,
I would say collaborating about rights
and who are entering hierarchical in
their fundamental orientation.
Most of the sustaining meaning that
people find in their lives is a
consequence of them adopting
responsibility.
And,
and that's,
that's something that's very much worth
deeply considered to be audience goes
Thailand because somehow it's encoded
into their psyche than if they adopt
responsibility.
Something good happens to them.
Well they know.
Yeah,
they definitely know what they ever
heard it articulated.
If there's two things that people
usually tell me when they come up to me,
which is another thing that's happened a
lot in the last year,
like I was just out yesterday,
walked down to the gym with my wife,
which is about five blocks later.
So when I was probably stopped by 15
people or so on the street,
you know,
15 minute period of time,
no one.
And that happens pretty much wherever I
go now regardless of the country,
which is also extremely interesting and
a testament to the insane breach of,
let's say youtube and podcasts.
People always tell me one of two things,
you know,
they say that they've been listening to
my youtube lectures or watching them or
podcasts or reading the book and that
that's been useful to them in terms of
finding direction and purpose and an
affirmation even though that's a word
that should be used very cautiously now
because it's sort of being mouth to
death,
a strength,
let's say an encouragement.
Those was a better words or they tell me
that it found words to describe things
they always knew to be true but didn't
know how to say.
This is also extremely useful for people
and perhaps the fundamental purpose of
intellectual adventure and discourse on
the humanities end of the distribution,
right?
To articulate truth,
ancient truths and to bring it up to
date and that's very useful for people
and see.
I kinda Kinda laid out a fairly standard
argument in some sense in the lectures.
The first a set of propositions and I
try to make them inviolable in some
sense propositions that no one would
disagree with.
The first is that life is very difficult
and rife with suffering and contaminated
by malevolence at every level.
There's natural level.
That's the proclivity of nature to try
to kill you,
and there's social malevolence and
individual malevolence and um,
and that worsens the essential tragedy
of life.
And so the fundamental truth as
religious types have always had this,
life is suffering.
The consequences of that is that you
need to sustaining meaning to,
to help you avoid bitterness.
And then the question is,
well,
where is that sustaining meaning to be
found?
If it can be found at all?
And the answer to that seems
to be not in rights and privileges,
sending pulse of freedom and
instantaneous gratification.
Not In any of that,
but in the adoption of responsibility
for the appalling conditions of the
world at all of those levels.
And then the determination to do
something about that.
And I do believe that people,
as soon as you tell people that they
understand it,
and it's partly because
I,
I speak to people about who they
spontaneously admired because aberration
is the instinct for imitation.
Let's at the themes in gladiator,
by the way.
Yes,
definitely.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Well,
it's one,
it's one of the themes of leadership per
say.
Hypothetically,
a leader is someone admirable and
someone admirable is someone that you
follow to follow,
is to imitate,
imitate this,
to practice a mode of being so that you
can undertake that motive being
autonomously.
Yeah.
So if you look at who or what you
spontaneously admired,
you could get some sense of what
constitutes that,
which is a value and it's inevitably,
I believe inevitably the people who are
admired are people who take
responsibility and the more
responsibility that they take,
the more admirable they become.
And so I don't see how any of that is,
is disputable in some fundamental sense.
Let's develop this further when we get
to glare.
I think that's a good.
That's a good point.
Um,
what I wanted to ask you,
you were quite recently actually,
you are in a breitbart event and turning
point USA.
And I want to just ask you a straight
question about that.
Where are you?
Are you comfortable there?
Well,
it wasn't a Friday.
It was a turning point USA event and I
was interviewed by Breitbart,
but
I thought it was,
I thought it was a dual event.
It had both Breitbart and turning point
on the,
on the posters.
Oh look,
that could be,
that could be.
It's not an indictment,
but I just felt
comfortable there.
Well,
yes,
no,
I mean no.
Uh,
uh,
I find American political events,
like I tend to view that to some degree
from the perspective of an
anthropologist.
The American political scene is very,
very different than the Canadian
evangelical element to the American
political scene that's completely
absent.
I'm
kind of a circus element and being
critical,
like there's some real enthusiasm
nearby,
but you could really see like a
Protestant revival isn't that
characterizes American political
discourse and I've seen that many of the
larger scale American political
spectacles that peripherally or century
involves.
That's strange and interesting.
But I wouldn't say it's a situation that
I feel particularly comfortable in.
Um,
I don't have any objection to speaking
in such events because I think that
whether or not I should speak at such a
dance is dependent to a large degree on
what it is that I'm speaking about and I
spoken twice to the turning point people
and I've outlined,
well a lot of the themes that I just
don't run with you and you know,
I've encouraged them to act
responsibility,
which I think is a message that
conservatives have that salable to young
people in a way that it,
it hasn't been for maybe three
generations.
Yes,
I understand.
So I'm also,
I'm not saying that they're bad people
you shooting per se,
should not be associated with the thing
is mostly that those events are so
ideologically hypercharged.
Yep.
And that's,
that's
my participation serves as a,
as a balance to that,
you know,
as something that brings it back down to
earth because I'm not talking to them as
Conservative Party activists,
let's say I'm talking to them as
individuals,
as people,
as individuals.
So,
um,
I,
I also,
at both turning point events that I've
attended,
I attempted to lay out the rationale for
the left of center viewpoint and to
explain why that also has to be taken
into account.
It's a strange thing in some sense that
they invite me because I'm not a
partisan person in any,
in any fundamental sense.
I've also been working quite extensively
with the Democrats in one manner in the
US as well,
trying to help a group of people who are
attempting to pull the central party
narrative away from the radical
leftists.
Yeah.
So when it comes to party politics,
your main thesis that I always hear from
you is that,
um,
the openness of say the left and the
proclivity for order for the ride,
I have to keep each other in balance in
the dialogue.
You want to ensure neither proclivity
become so polarized or both so that the
dialogue ceases then well then you have
something approximating,
well if not more than at least conflict
or repression or.
Right?
So yes,
you don't have to watch the experience
and you have to keep the dialogue going.
That can be managed.
I think this is a good point to
transition to the identity politics
chapter of our talk.
So what I wanted to discuss is,
and well it's narrative substitution and
this is kind of.
I came up with it myself and don't ever
makes any sense but sounds impressive
and that's good enough for me.
So what I kinda mean by this,
Eric Weinstein,
last September with Dave Rubin,
he inserted that the concept of safe
spaces don't serve to protect
individuals.
They serve to protect narratives that
can cannot survive scrutiny from the
outside world.
So I've tried to develop this,
this thought a little further and I came
up with the following thought that I
wanted to present to you.
I'm in identity politics.
People's actual individual experience is
replaced by the embodiment of a
narrative of collective oppression,
which doesn't necessarily reflect their
actual position in society.
So in short,
there are not as oppressed as the
narrative.
They subscribe to big states.
You
the data on that from the logical
literature is quite clear.
If you,
if you survey minority group members,
let's say
they almost inevitably state the amount
of oppression suffered by their group,
far exceeds the oppression they
experienced as individuals.
Very common finding.
Yep.
So,
so how do we,
how do you cope with this very grave
disparity between data and narrative and
never different body by individuals even
though it doesn't reflect their actual
position in society?
Well,
let's,
let's go back a couple of steps to your
original propositions.
Weinstein's conference for example,
were that the purpose of safe spaces
wasn't to protect individuals,
but to protect a narrative that may or
scrutiny.
I certainly believe that because when.
This is something I hope to do in the
next year,
I've been looking into some of the
fundamental propositions of the identity
politics and of the political spectrum,
the idea of patriarchy,
the idea of intersectionality,
the idea that
what would you call it,
performance increments can be accrued as
a consequence of diversification of view
points along the standard identity
politics lines.
Those ideas are intellectually week
almost beyond comprehension.
Yeah.
The only,
and I looked up,
I think it was Kate Millett,
my,
my memory might be fading.
I looked,
I looked up the research,
let's call it on the idea of white
privilege on the idea of the Patriarchy
and the idea of intersectionality and I
went and tracked down the people who
formulated the ideas and started to look
seriously at what they have written and
discussed and frankly it's me
intellectually week and I think the only
reason it survived at all is because so
it was all formulated in the
universities.
The idea of white privilege,
for example,
was formulated that wet else.
We had the idea of intersectionality at
the law school at Ucla and I think the
only reason that these ideas have gained
currency is the serious scholars in
universities and those were mostly but
not all be those who are pursuing a
research in the stem disciplines.
Because of the fundamental corruption of
the humanities and the social sciences
have just ignored them.
They haven't been subject to January
criticism.
Hypothetically.
They're peer reviewed,
but they're peer reviewed by people
who've already taken the poison,
let's say,
or who are possessed by the same set of
ideas.
As soon as you analyze those ideas,
they fall apart.
So other disciplines,
other academic disciplines have plainly
ignored this.
Yeah,
well,
I think it's because they never thought
that the ideas were worthy of criticism,
which has a real criticism.
Your ideas aren't even worthy of
criticism.
We're going to ignore them,
and the problem is is that's actually
not worked out very well because,
well,
the stem types,
let's say we're busy peering through the
microscopes,
the activist pipes were busy corrupting
the entire structure of the university
and then spreading that,
that pathology of appallingly bad ideas
out into the broader culture,
like the idea of intersectionality.
We run a real focus on that.
It's like we could just take that apart
for a bit.
So first of all,
to be an intersection,
intersection list,
if that's a word,
means that you have to buy the
oppression narrative.
You have to buy the narrative.
That history isn't a battle ground
between the oppressed and the
oppressors.
That's the first thing.
So that's a Marxist presumption derived
from,
I would say it's an analog of the
proletariat.
[inaudible] struggled that was outlined
as fundamental marks.
So it's a very bad,
I don't think there's any doubt about
that jeff or Bible out and I don't,
I think it's an appalling poetry one
side or the idea,
even though there is oppression and that
characterizes all social institutions,
um,
but that's by no means all the story
then you have to buy the idea that the
oppression occurs along the canonical
lines drawn identity lines drawn by the
identity politics type.
So that would be essentially,
let's say race,
ethnicity,
sexuality and gender as an article,
uh,
categories and I don't think the
evidence for that is overwhelming as
well.
And then having accepted those
propositions,
unquestionably,
they,
you noticed that oppression is more than
one dimensional St.
Well,
if you're black and female,
then your oppression is either the
summer or the product of those two
minority statuses.
Um,
I don't find that particularly
compelling or original idea.
I think it's obvious and it's also self
contradictory and it's easy to think
that through because as you multiply the
number of identically
which you could be oppressed,
you reduced the number of people in each
super ordinate category and my
suspicions are that you could figure
this out,
arithmetically with a bit of work
approximately.
At least imagine that each person can be
placed into 10 idea identity categories
switch,
which I don't think it's unreasonable.
The actually the number of categories is
the limit.
It's limitless.
You ended up with no groups.
You end up right back to the individual
and so so which is essentially what the
West discovered.
I would say it's some multiple thousands
of years ago.
It's really want to take everybody's
differences into account which is what
the intersection was claim you should be
doing and what you end up doing is
responding to each person as if you're a
unique individual.
So and that's just one example of how
unbelievably show these ideas are and
how,
how easily they're subject to what I
would say devastating criticism and that
does support.
Yeah.
But I do think that what is often
overlooked,
because they're so dominant in our,
the way our perception is shaped what is
often overlooked.
But actually very few people subscribe
to identity politics.
I think there was only
one study,
uh,
yeah,
at around 8,000 people.
And the conclusion was that only eight
percent actually subscribed to this
narrative and
media and education.
Well,
you can imagine,
you can hypothesize that the political,
if you consider political affiliation
unit dimensional,
it's not clear that you could make a
normal distribution.
The extremes are rare and yeah.
Then of course the question is how do
you define what constitutes extreme,
but it does appear that a reasonable
estimate on both the right and the left
is something approximating five to eight
percent.
And in that same study,
even the people who were identified as
relatively extreme in relationship to
their left wing identity politics
position of 40 percent of them had also
agreed with the idea that political
correctness has gone too far.
Yeah.
So this identity narrative is basically
it has consolidated its position in the
universities
and then media
and human resources departments in large
corporations as well.
And I wouldn't underestimate the danger
of that.
That's,
that's the new fifth.
Call them inside the capitalist system
itself,
welcomed by the capitalists who want to
have it both ways,
but you have to give the identitarian
seven,
they're due credit because if their,
if their doctor is indeed as
intellectually week as it appears to us,
they've accomplished quite a lot with
it.
Yes.
Well continuous subsidies for 40 years.
House and hurt,
you know,
what they've managed to do is blur the
distinction between education and
indoctrination and it's easy to blur
that distinction because you would hope
that to some degree what people you
learn in university can be transposed
into action now.
And so drawing a distinction between
education and indoctrination is very
good to call thing.
Um,
but it still needs to be done.
I've recommended to politicians,
Canada and the US mostly in Canada so
far that they
ask universities to generate in Ontario
with my home problems.
The newly elected conservative
government has required the universities
and colleges to formulate a statement,
a free speech policy statement,
and all of the colleges in Ontario have
now complied and most of them have
adopted some variant of the Chicago
University of Chicago statement,
which is a real move forward and I've
been thinking that an equally useful
thing to do would be to ask ologist in
universities to formulate policy,
dissociating education from
indoctrination.
And there is precedent for this.
That's nonpartisan.
So for the Canadian Revenue Agency,
which is equivalent to the irs in the US
tax agency for bids charities from
engaging in political activism.
And so that means there's already a set
of definitions regarding what
constitutes activism.
Say rather than charitable work,
which
something that can be useful.
You applied in the education field
distinguishing activism from education.
Because the problem is is that part of
the problem is is that there is a small
minority of very disruptive people,
in my estimation,
who have been subsidized or they're
destructive work for about 50 years.
And that's given them a power that's far
of proportion to their intellectual
rigor,
to the credibility of their ideas and to
their numerical prevalence.
Yeah,
makes sense.
And I think that the way to defeat this
is to embody that the male archetype or
ear or I know men or women
doesn't really matter.
So I think we can go through that third
point,
just make a swot.
It's just big aside.
Move quickly because I'm sure.
Well,
so one of the things that's happened in
Hungary,
for example,
the president has cuts funding,
if I remember correctly,
to women's studies and I know that in
Brazil there's no pressure being placed
now,
I don't know this very well on my part,
but there's pressure being placed on
lgbt activists trips and so you could
say that one way of dealing with the
unfortunate and I'm reasonable
subsidization of this particular
political viewpoint would be to stop
funding that at the university or public
level.
But the problem with that is it opens up
the specter of direct government
interference with the autonomy be bad.
So then we can go to the other topic,
which is I think the way that you
undermine a bad story,
no undermine is right.
I think the way that you engage in
proper discourse in relationship to set
video,
logical presuppositions is by
formulating and communicating better
story or better story with.
And that's a better transition.
Well,
hopefully,
well,
hopefully it's the right way of going
about it.
He person who tells the best story wins
and that that echoes back to Weinstein's
caution that the purpose of the safe
springs,
which are clearly purpose of this space,
is clearly not to produce more resilient
individuals.
Jonathan Heit and his coauthor,
it just finished the American mind just
published,
look,
Yanis Ganahl the piano off his name.
Um,
lay out the evidence that the safe space
doctrine actually weakens individuals
very clearly than I think any reasonable
psychologist or a psychiatrist knows the
literature on exposure to anxiety
provoking stimuli would have to agree
that protecting people from any exposure
to things that they're afraid of or
contentious like Lidl to weaken them
rather than just cranking them.
So I think it is to protect the
narrative.
Um,
yeah,
and,
but I think the best way to combat and
pathological narrative a better story.
Yeah,
I agree.
And talking about or stories I think I
would now like to discuss one of the
best stories I've seen in modern cinema
and I'm talking about the movie
gladiator that came out in 2000 starting
Russia crow and Jacqueline Phoenix.
You totally,
you saw last night?
Yeah,
I had watched it before so I knew we
were going to talk about it.
So
I was very surprised.
I don't know how I avoided it
now.
And then there's a movie of substantial
cultural significance that you just miss
and that was what I missed.
So yeah.
Yeah.
Well you made up for it.
Um,
so gladiator,
I think this movie is ingrained in the
psyche of my generation more so than any
other,
like epic,
epic movie of it's open source.
So there's not a character's,
there's,
there's Aragorn from Lord of the rings.
There's hector from Troy is William
Wallace from braveheart or spartacus.
There's Leah night is from 300.
All these characters are the same
archetipal figures,
but somehow only maximum ms dot meridius
really strict,
really sticks through the years.
And I have,
uh,
I've,
I've put some thought into this and I
have some ideas about why particularly
this character in this movie sticks.
I wanted to present to you three points
that culminate in what I think is the
implicit central thesis difference
throughout the movie.
So I'm going to list now the three
points and then the central thesis or
number one is that maximum,
this is by far the best modern portrayal
of the male archetypes.
I'm,
he's highly capable,
but very gentle and these modest in word
and body language and these admired and
loved solely for his character and
skill.
So that's the,
that's the portrayal of the architect's
going to,
is that the movie also contains the very
best modern portrayal of the embittered
villain whose character and skill are
simply insufficient and he makes up for
it through deceit and cruelness while
still knowing every step of the way that
eventually build it.
There's nothing you can do about it.
And three,
the characters themselves are exclusive
in their own rights,
but in this movie there juxtaposition
within a hostile brother framework which
makes it,
which is a deeply architecture
framework,
which might be the reason that it's,
it sticks so much more than all the
other architects figures.
And this brings me to the central
thesis.
And,
um,
I only figured this out two days ago and
I'm very excited to get to share this
with you.
I think that central complicit thesis
throughout the whole movie is as
follows,
that no matter how powerful someone is,
the bane of a man who sold,
who has been irreversibly corrupted far
out exceeds the pain of a righteous man
whose wife and son had been murdered and
has been reduced to epic,
which is really something to think
about.
Oh yeah.
Right.
Okay.
So the themes that you've been
developing.
Okay.
So the first thing we might also note
that
last over,
maybe that's the right way of thinking
about it.
You said
Maximus is a paragon of soldierly
virtue,
right?
He's physical combat and a warrior
beautiful up.
He serves his commander,
but also serves the principals.
More importantly,
principles that govern his commander
principals more than the commander
himself and you can tell that because he
chooses not to serve the new emperor
because he doesn't believe that he
abides by the proper principles.
And Communists of course also killed his
own father,
which means that he killed the
principles by which the state,
um,
he's like,
he's like elder gods in the Mesopotamian
creationists who kill app suit,
who's their father,
and then try to live on this course.
It doesn't work out well for them.
All that does is breed chaos.
And that's exactly what happens in the
movie gladiator.
Maximus as son is an interesting son,
is also an interesting character because
he becomes son as a consequence of his
virtue rather than as a consequence of
his birthright.
Carbon has the,
has the advantage of birth,
but maximus has the advantage of virtue
is the virtue of strength.
And you know,
that makes the movie in some sense also
extremely barbaric.
There's just endless and killing,
which is very strange thing when you're
talking about someone who's operating
within a fundamentally moral framework.
And I guess part of the moral of the
story is that it's better to be a
soldier than a coward
and that's,
you know,
that's,
it's not.
I would say that on one hand that self
evident and on the other hand that's a
mystery because the coward might be able
to avoid the mayhem and killing that
characterizes the life of the soldier
anyways.
Maximus does organize himself under the
virtues of courage and,
and for parents and strength.
Yeah.
So my observation is actually of course,
is a very powerful soldier,
but my observation is that that is not
the reason.
Not so much the reason this archetype
sticks.
Hello?
I read this character that he is the
absolute embodiment of the
characteristics that allow you to
content with tragedy and malevolence in
an optimal way,
not just on the battlefield.
It's not really about the battlefield.
Right.
Well,
you see,
you see his soldierly capability as a
representation of competence itself
guided by principles.
Yeah.
I think that's reasonable.
I also think that that's probably how
the conduct of the soldier should be
judged.
It that soldiers are necessary despite
the mayhem that warfare produces.
We haven't figured out how to dispense
with that.
So do you think.
Sorry.
Do you think that Kayden,
do you think that the Cain and Abel
framework in which it is implicitly a
structure it,
do you think that adds to do how much a
story sticks?
Yes,
definitely.
Why is that?
Well,
because the story of Cain and Abel does
lay out very,
very elegantly and and it was incredible
compression to fundamentally opposed
modes of being both being characterized
as able to favorite song.
The most being that characterizes Cain
and Abel is competent and virtuous and
God theory,
let's say,
but more practically,
which means he's allied with the highest
of principles.
That's the right way to think about it
psychologically.
Whatever the higher the highest of
principals might be.
There was an attempt.
One of the things that you might
consider psychologically is that the
movement from polytheism to monotheism
parallels parallels the integration of
the individual psyche and the
development of larger and larger scale
social organizations.
All those things happened at the same
time,
so you imagine that the larger scale,
the organization,
the human organization,
so the more people included under the
umbrella of the same state,
the more organized and orderly the
principles by which that state have to
function must be because of the
increasing complexity and also the the
problem of having to determine how the
state can remain intact over a long
period of time without fragment,
so the state has to organize itself so
that the needs and wants of the bulk of
the population are met with sufficient
regularity so that the state itself
doesn't fragment and that means that the
state has to organize itself in what you
might regard as a virtuous manner.
That can be iterated and at the same
time the people who compose the state in
its increasing complexity have to ally
themselves with that longterm state
goal.
So it's a.
it's a.
it's a coalition between psychological
integration and sociological complexity
and and that's,
that is foreshadowed we might say,
or accompany by the movement from
polytheism,
which is the polling of people in all
directions by fundamental,
motivational and natural forces.
Into monotheism,
which is the direction of the
under the rubric of a single set of
principles.
So single super ordinate set of
Now what those principles are not
obvious,
which is partly why we're having the
discussion of gladiator.
So I can give you an example of this.
So for example,
um,
in the Old Testament,
you see the articulation of the guiding
principles emerge in its most fully
formed manner with the commandments of
Moses.
So you might say all of the diverse
sources that might be polled people,
hither and yon have being aggregated
into a list of thou shalt nots.
Here's how to regulate yourself.
Here's how to get yourself across time
so that you can have a stable,
longterm,
large scale society.
But then there's a mystery that emerges
in the New Testament,
which is,
it emerges,
for example,
with Christ is asked by the scribes and
Pharisees,
which is the greatest of the
commandments.
And Christ actually performs a very
intelligent sleight of hand.
And he says,
well,
you have to love God with all your heart
and all your soul.
And you have to love your brother as if
he's yourself.
Love your neighbor as yourself on,
on those propositions,
all the commandments and the law.
There's an attempt to integrate even the
commandments into something that's a
higher order principle and that
principle actually manifests itself in
Judeo Christian society as the logos,
whatever that is,
and it's something like truthful
communication devoted towards the
highest good and the embodiment of that
becomes the fundamental principle.
And in gladiator you see movement
towards that and embodiment,
right?
Because maximus is an organized and
disciplined person who's governed by
principles.
The question is,
and the question is posed throughout the
movie,
well,
what his role right now asked for,
asked by Marcus Aurelius because he
failed log.
What he's done is a failure.
It's asked by communists and it's asked
by the sister whose,
whose name escapes me at the moment.
It's what?
I think it's loosened.
Okay?
Okay.
Um,
and they all asked for what his role,
but she comes the closest.
She says it's a great idea,
but it's not.
It's an animating principle.
And the question is,
what is the animating principle?
Now,
whatever it is,
maximus embodies that far more than
common does.
And maximus is a able figure l whereas
comedy or comedic is
clearly a failure of,
of cane,
makes it proper sacrifices and they're
never well regarded.
He says constantly,
you know,
that he,
all he ever did was try to please his
father.
Well,
his sacrifices went on,
appreciate it.
And that's what made him bitter and
resentful and murderous and catastrophic
death and evil and to tyrant and all
that stuff.
So yes,
fundamentally archetypical structure.
So who do you.
This is like a compressed version of the
thesis.
Who Do you think in this story?
Is it common as well?
It's the same question that the social,
it's posted in the Gulag archipelago to
some degree.
It's like,
do,
do you want to lose your.
What's worse to put your life at risk,
let's say,
or to put everything you love at risk or
they lose your conscience.
And Solzhenitsyn's conclusion was that
there's no suffering greater than that
which accompanies last
exhale.
There's something very,
very profound about that because one of
the things I've just been reading about
this,
interestingly enough,
that was the prophet Elijah who,
who first seems to have.
It's in the story of the profitable,
profitable Asia as far as I can tell,
where there's the first intimation that
God might speak to human beings,
not as the external force of natural
power,
storms,
fire,
wind,
winter earthquakes,
all the,
all the overwhelming natural forces that
human beings were subject to or maybe
even not as internal forces that would
more characterize some of the other
polytheistic gods like lost or rage or
or terror,
but as the voice of conscience itself,
which which is which is described in one
kings which is this contains the story
of Elijah asked the still small voice.
That's the first time that that frees.
It merges and so it's the idea that
there's something that there's a
psychological factor conscious itself
that calls to you,
that that has a dialogue with you.
Even more importantly because it's
conscious,
doesn't tell you what to do.
It hints at what you shouldn't do and it
isn't a deterministic force.
It's not like when your conscious
scripts you,
you're forced to act in a manner that's
in accordance with your conscience.
You can choose to violate it,
and so there's this idea that God
transforms himself or becomes known as
the voice of conscience and the facts,
the late between human beings and
divinity itself.
I actually think this is a highly
credible hypothesis.
Let's say that what you need and
powerful sustaining meaning to keep you
from the bitterness of cane and that's
to be found in the relationship with
something of divine significance.
Well,
maybe that's mediated through your
conscience
and this relationship is absent within
Kane.
He severed his relationship with
consciousness and consciousness,
but with conscience,
conscience of
conscious.
Yeah.
Well,
that's right,
because conscience,
his management conscience is the
manifestation of the instate for good
and evil.
Yeah.
Nope.
So we can take the argument that a
little bit about what makes people
bitter is that they feel that there is
wrong in the world.
It might be a large scale.
Society is unfair.
The natural world is a catastrophe.
Human beings are intrinsically
malevolent that the structure of being
itself is wrong in some moral sense.
Okay,
but that's interesting because they
wouldn't be bothered by that if they
didn't have some sense of morality
itself.
Well,
that what that means is that conscious,
even the conscious that's driving them
towards their cynicism is the dawning of
the realization of a moral dimension to
life.
Now,
conscience doesn't seem to manifest
itself as an alien force that cannot be
denied.
It's more something that beckons and
Harkins and also something that you need
to enter into a negotiation with.
Interestingly enough,
in the Old Testament,
even before the transformation of God,
let's say into the voice of conscience,
you have continual intimations that
whatever.
Yeah,
wait,
is is something that can be negotiated
with.
So for example,
Abraham negotiates with Yahuah when he
tries to save the inhabitants of Sodom
from being decimated by God's wrath,
he bargains.
He says,
well,
if I could find 50 good men,
will you spare the city?
And God says,
yes.
It's one of,
if I can find 20,
if I could find 10,
if I can find a single good map.
And God,
strangely enough,
despite his own audience,
agrees this bargain,
and so god,
even in the Old Testament,
the Old Testament,
God's often pilloried as a very
intransigent and tyrannical va,
but it's clear even in the earlier
stories that he could be negotiated
with,
oddly enough.
Then you see the same thing with Jacob
who eventually becomes Israel,
right?
And Israel means he who wrestles with
God,
which is very,
very interesting idea,
right?
Is that if God can be assimilated to
conscience,
then what that means is that the true
followers of God are those who wrestled
with their conscience and Jacob,
before he's transformed into Israel.
Jacob's a trickster figure,
right?
He's a.
he's a maneuver.
He's a salesman.
He's a.
he's someone who's not above using
trickery to gain is an because he cheats
his brother,
for example,
out of his birthright,
and that is subject to the same
treatment at the hands of his uncle,
but in any case,
he's not classically moral person,
but he wrestles with the angel on the
banks of the river when he returns to
see the product that he's betrayed and
he wrestled all night with an angel who
also turns out to be God who puts his
hip joint.
It's a very contentious battle and he
actually defeats the angel who is gone
and requires him to bless it in the
morning,
and the blessing is that Jacob will now
be called Israel,
and that's he who wrestles successfully
with believably interesting sequence of
ideas because it all.
It also speaks,
I think,
to something approximating human
destiny.
It's like,
well,
what's the purpose of man with God in
God's absence?
What will say,
forget God's absence for a moment,
but assuming God,
what's the purpose of man given the
garden to the president and,
and,
and I'm
omnipotent.
What's the purpose of man?
And it looks like the the fundamental
idea that's emerging as monotheism
emergency in the West is that go on and
enter into a partnership to cocreate the
world.
It's something like that and that,
that you do that under the guidance of
your conscious.
So the destiny of men would be to
transcend in dialog with God
symbolically speaking,
yes,
and to overcome suffering to the degree
that that can be managed and to overcome
malevolence to the degree that that can
be managed at the dialogue with God.
That's.
That's the idea that emerges.
That's the great monotheistic idea and
the thing that it sort of a
continuation,
but stay up the argument I was making
out with you before about responsibility
in meaning.
It's like,
well,
let's.
Let's assume that you find meaning and
responsibility and that you need a
meeting that will sustain you through
suffering and malevolence.
It's like,
well,
where's that?
Well,
let's say it's to be found in hearkening
to the clarion call of conscience.
It cody's like,
I can't see how that's wrong.
Maybe if you can also reverse engineer
it,
that if you take communists as a test
case,
that when you sever the relationship
between the individual,
the individual and conscious,
then suffering is maximized.
Well,
look,
he's.
He suffers terribly isolated from
everyone,
but the the thing he suffers most from
is the fact that is alienated from his
father.
Right.
And that,
that,
that torments him terribly.
And that's actually why he hates maximus
so much.
Retail against the team enabled stories
because Maximus,
for all of the terrible things that's
happened to him,
he's never severed from the father.
Yeah,
and that's the thing come you just
cannot tolerate.
And I do think that this suffering
exceeds that of maximus.
Yeah,
perfect.
Because it's so pointless
to me.
It's such a striking and interesting
idea then that then to be corrupt,
until it's more suffering than to be the
victim of corruption.
If you're righteous,
you're righteous victim.
It feels so profound and not,
not not that intuitively true because
maximum he loses everything.
His wife and son are murdered.
He didn't slip,
so it's not
as common as emperor.
Yeah,
so it's not at face value.
Obvious then maximus suffers less than
comedy is,
right.
I agree with it,
but it seems,
but it seems to be the thesis running
throughout the theme was perhaps the
only reason that Maxima suffers less to
some degree is that the fact that he's
maintained,
his virtue makes this suffering
bearable,
and you see that as well.
When he has the argument with the man
who comes to own him,
the former of gladiator decides to do
the honorable thing and to smuggle
maximum sort of the of the prison.
He also decides to to take the path of
virtue.
That in some sense gives a transcendent
meaning to his life.
Yet every deems him because he wasn't.
He was also.
He was also a miserable.
Right,
right,
and so,
but the redemption that interesting
there too.
The redemption comes at the cost of his
own death and there's a very interesting
architectural theme there as well
because it is seeing what happens is
monotheism develops in the West as a
carbonates,
at least along the Christian mind,
is thinking in the figure of Christ,
is that the principle that becomes the
highest ideal is
the.
It's the mode of being that takes
suffering voluntarily onto itself as
it's full responsibility,
right?
That's the acceptance of the
crucifixion,
the betrayal that goes along with it.
So yeah,
you know,
Christ spaces statement in the desert,
so that's the confrontation with
malevolence and accepts the necessity of
its own bodily death,
so that's natural.
That's the.
That's the terrible power of nature
manifested in death and the terrible
power of society manifested in the
ability to punch,
so any faces,
all of those things voluntarily,
and the the,
the,
the
psychological process that enables that
in some sense of the transcendence is
the death and rebirth,
rebirth,
and to be redeemed means allow yourself
to die when necessary.
See what happens with the,
with the,
with the gladiator,
the head gladiators.
He allows himself to die necessary.
Now he dies a physical death,
but there's,
but there's metaphysical deaths that can
be undertaken continually.
It's a spiritual death.
It's like if you encounter,
if you find yourself entangled in
corruption and you need to set yourself
right as a consequence,
what that means is that you have to
sacrifice some of yourself to the
erroneous part of yourself and so the
idea is that you can.
You can die and be reborn in a spiritual
sense.
That's what baptism is,
for example,
and that that's what leads you is the
identification with that part of you
that will die and be reborn in the
furtherance in pursuit of a higher
order.
Principles
are then.
That's what the Holy Ghost.
I think that's the idea of the holy
ghost fleets as like a gel or something
like that.
Let me just see what.
What would be the best transition
because we do more complex,
which we're talking about.
Art is the next thing and you wanted to
refer us to the last two.
So we still have individualization,
individuation.
Let's start with art,
but look,
look,
I mean I was looking,
for example,
at a painting last night which was
Rafales transfiguration of Christ,
and it's this,
so the transfiguration occurs when
Christ goes up on the mountain with his
disciples,
I think it's Peter,
James and John,
and on the mountain he meets Moses,
so bearer of the mosaic law,
and he meets a lot of show and Elijah is
a prophet who encounters the still small
voice and he's transfigured,
his face shines.
His clothing is,
is,
is lightened to an unbearable,
some like whiteness and it's.
It's too much for the disciples to
tolerate to see all this and so,
so that's his transfiguration.
Then when he comes down from the
mountaintop,
this is all portrayed in this painting
for she seemed the transfiguration at
the top.
You see the second part of the story at
the bottom,
he comes down and he cast that demon out
of a young man and I thought,
well,
that's unbelievably apropos because
you know,
while you're smiling,
you can see why it's apropos.
At least to some degree.
It's like I think that we all have the
proclivity to be possessed to to a
greater or lesser degree by the modern
day equivalent of of demons and that's
ideological possession or possession by
cynicism,
possession by that cynicism
characterized in possession by nihilism
or these totalitarian ideologies and the
question is,
well,
how are those cast out?
And the answer is,
and this is portrayed in the painting,
it's portrayed in the story,
but strange story of Christ's
transfiguration and its association with
Moses and Elijah,
unbelievably complex narrative
structures,
right?
Pointing at something that was not fully
articulated like that's intuited by the
storytellers and the artist step,
the willingness to die and be reborn in
the service of the highest principle is
the process by which possession is
eradicated.
That's an idea that idea so
overwhelmingly complicated and
sophisticated than it has to be dreamed
up and it has to be represented
artistically before it can be
comprehended.
The painting by Rafaelle,
the one I'm describing that was regarded
as the greatest oil painting in the
world for 300 years.
It's a non trivial piece of art like I
think it was painted.
Let me just,
let me just check this because I might
as well get the date right.
It was a renaissance painting.
Rafaelle.
Okay,
so from 15,
20 to 18,
20,
that was regarded as the greatest oil
painting in the world.
That's three centuries.
That's.
You got it.
You got to think about something like
that happens,
like what's being represented there?
Well,
I think it's what's being represented is
something akin to what I've just been
discussing and that's a good example of
how the artists to storytellers and at
the end the image makers are lay the
pathway for articulated representations.
You see the same thing happening in
cardiac,
right?
Because it's a story but.
But there's a moral to the story and
there's a pointer towards an articulated
set of principles potentially
articulated set of principles.
So the idea you just laid out,
you think that it had to be.
It had to manifest itself in a dream
restory version before it could be
articulated like in an operational way.
Yeah.
Because of the ideas have to look.
The way I look at it this,
this waves,
first of all,
to some degree these ideas are encoded
in behavior.
So for example,
in Exodus,
Moses received the law,
but remember before he received the law,
he's wandering around in the desert for
a long time,
so it's in chaos with with a group of
extraordinary these
who are constantly fighting amongst
themselves and who are constantly
tempted to worship other idols.
So in in a chaotic state.
Then the temptation of principles,
we really manifest itself.
What principle should be guiding us and
that's portrayed in the exit was story
as the proclivity to chase after false.
Now the Israelites actually come to
Moses for a very long period of time in
pairs or families to adjudicate
disputes,
and so he does that to the point of
exhaustion.
This is prior to receiving the 10
commandments,
and so what's what happens with the 10
commandments.
As Moses comes to realize to revelation,
he comes to realize it and articulated
manner to principles that the Israelites
are already,
to some degree implicitly guided by that
actually produce peace and harmony
behavioral patterns that no one knows
what they are because they're not
conscious enough that they have mapped
themselves enough.
So the mosaic revelation is part of that
process of mapping and the mapping
itself is represented in the story of
Moses and within the story of Moses is
actually contained the articulated
virtue,
the commandments,
let's say,
but that's only part of the process of
the unfolding of the virtue.
It still doesn't answer the question,
which is the question.
It's eventually posted to Christ.
It's like,
well,
that's all well and good,
but what's the highest virtue?
Well,
that's,
that's any insanely complicated question
because it's no different than,
well,
how should you conduct your life?
Right?
It's,
it's the hardest questions,
and so we've had to gather as a
collective.
We've had to gather information about,
well,
what is it?
What does it look like when someone,
when a particular person lives in
undesirable life?
We tell the story of someone who lives
in undesirable life or maybe he tells
his own story and then we aggregate a
hundred stories of undesirable life and
then we abstract out from those stories
what constitutes undesirable and so
that's like a picture of cane,
right?
It's a portrait of cane.
We do the same thing on the other side.
We we listen to people who who've lived
triumphantly and we aggregate their
stories and we set the size of you say,
well then we we,
we extract from that a portrait of able
and that's a precursor like
the successful and the unsuccessful are
precursors to Abel and Cain and Abel and
Cain are precursors to the divine,
the divine finger,
so the divine figures of Christ that
Satan,
right?
It's,
it's an abstract process of continual
abstraction and that's all done through
at least to begin with through ritual
and narrative and art is so complicated.
It can't be done then the other way,
so first it's acted out and an entrusted
domain of ritual art and narratives.
Then it becomes operational like an
traditional loop,
right?
Because once,
well,
once you get the image of the ritual,
then those modes of communication start
to alter behavior,
you know,
so it's like,
well,
that's why we're having this discussion.
We're talking about,
we're talking about a movie that's an
artistic representation and we're
discussing it to articulate principles
and we're also articulating those
principles so that in principle our
behavior can be altered.
And I never thought about the loop.
Oh yeah.
See these things,
these things feed back,
right?
So the,
it's,
it's the collective behavior.
It's that negotiation at the collective
level,
fractious centuries long linear,
long negotiation that produces something
like that.
Synthesis synthesis is represented in,
in drama and mythology and ritual and
art.
Then next articulate.
But those notes.
And so the whole process starts to
spiral up,
spiral upward editing,
increasingly rapid rate.
So look,
when I was always wondering that if this
archetypal patterns that lead to the
most favorable life are already known
for such a long time,
why does any,
every generation seems to have to invent
them.
And you know,
there's,
there's no to known like one of the
things but plato,
socrates insisted on was that learning
was remembering.
Okay,
so let's say that when you're born you,
you have a proclivity to manifest the
number of patterns and you certainly do.
You can manifest the patterns of rage
and fear and hunger and thirst and like,
but,
but then also imagined,
okay,
so it's something like this,
as this looping process occurred,
the people who are more likely to
manifest the pattern that is being
pointed to are more practically likely
to live and to successfully propagate.
So there's an evolutionary elephant that
the society values something and the
degree to which you manifest that value
is proportionate to your success and
your success is proportionate to your
reproductive fitness.
Then as that overtime the proclivity for
that sort of ethical behavior will
become coded in some sense in your
genetic structure selected for,
for that.
So then you might say,
well that exists.
This is Mrs. What the archetype is.
In some sense it exists as the
possibility of being gripped by a
particular kind division.
Now there might be enough diversity in
the ideal so that you can't emerge from
the womb
fully Christian if you don't know what I
mean,
but that doesn't mean that there won't
be something that can suit you as a
consequence of observing the
manifestation of a kind of ideal and it
doesn't to you because otherwise you
wouldn't be gripped by the damn stories.
But here's the rub to it.
Can't be hard coded.
Exactly.
So here's,
here's something interesting about
Christianity.
It was actually posed as an interesting
question in and the musical Jesus Christ
superstar near the end,
um,
the,
the actor who played Judas asked Christ
after he's dead,
that sort of a,
there's a scene where everyone's singing
and dancing.
It's a strange sort of disco scene.
And Judas asks why Christ had to come to
Earth at such a strange time and in such
an isolated place because he appears as
a carpenter in a region,
you know,
2000 years ago.
Why then,
why is there?
And that answer is the divine principle
has to manifest itself constantly within
the confines of an individual life.
With all of the peculiar idiosyncrasies
and limitation for that individual life,
and so part of the reason that the ideal
beckons is because you can't just be
born as Christ
because Christ represents,
let's say,
this overarching idea.
It's actually been union of the divine
with the particulars of your time and
place and so because your particular
eyes.
Then you have to determine how to
manifest the archetype in your
conditions and your specific conditions
that's partly associated with that
dialogue with your conscious,
so there's an architecture mode of being
supposedly,
ideally we'd have to integrate in with
your surroundings and what needs to be
met.
That's right.
It has to be manifest in the particulars
of your time and place.
That's the individuation process.
That's exactly what it is because you
regard the self.
You'll regard to Christ as a symbol of
the self.
He actually reversed the spiritual and
the psychological and sociological and
psychological,
and he thought he was thinking about the
cosmic Christ as for Yoga,
selfless,
the totality of individual,
but it was everything that you were
right
now,
everything that you were in the past,
but also everything that you could
possibly become a cross your set of
potential futures.
Here's there's one paragraph from young
then I'm going to send to you in the
chat right now and I would like to ask
you if you could,
could read it out.
It's not that long because I think that
illustrates exactly what what you're
talking about.
I'm sending you a link.
If you click on it,
it's an image.
What is summit is for each
when the bug unfolds and from the lesser
to greater emergence.
As Nietzsche says,
one becomes two and a greater faker,
which always was but which remained
invisible appears to the lesser
personality with the force of
revelation.
Yes,
and that's the manifestation of the
self.
That's right.
What that is is an intimation of who you
could be and it's also an intimation of
what you're associated with.
That might guide you to what you could
be,
so you might say it's a revelation of
your old core stability,
but it's your rev revelation of your
possibility in relationship to something
that's infinite transcendent.
Yeah.
That's the one I would also say that
that does.
That is also very commonly manifested by
a transformation in the relationship
with conscious because when something
like this happens,
sometimes this happens to people,
for example,
in a hallucinatory or psychedelic
experiences,
right?
They start to take their conscience
seriously as the CEO believed,
at least to some degree that
what guided your interest and that would
include your conscious was a
manifestation of the totality of the
self in the restricted domain of the
present.
Okay,
so that's.
so.
So okay.
Which one always was,
but which remained invisible,
right?
That's the heavenly father.
That would be.
The markets are really as principal,
that manifested itself in,
in,
in Maximus that resists and which
markets really has also made himself
subordinate to at least to some degree,
right?
That's the one which always was,
but which remained invisible.
Yeah.
He was truly an hopelessly little will
always drank.
The revelation of the greater down to
the level of this littleness and will
never understand that the day of
judgment for his littleness has dawn,
the man who is inwardly great.
We'll know that the long expected friend
of his soul,
the immortal one has now really come to
lead captivity captive.
That is to seize hold of him by who was
a mortal,
had always been confined and held
prisoner and to make his life flow into
that greater life.
A moment of deadliest peril.
Just prophetic vision of the tightrope
Walker reveals the awful danger that
lies in having a tight rope,
walking attitude towards an event to
which St Paul gave the most exalted name
he could find.
Yeah,
that's quite a.
that's quite the densely pack.
That one
it's from.
It's from the archetypes and the
collective unconscious page 1:21 if
that's volume one,
right?
Because volume two is ion,
which is even more frightening books,
so yes,
because in apparel talks about there is
the parallel psychosis at least in part
inflation because the manifestation of
that,
that second figure,
but say the self,
it's,
it's a devil's temptation as well
because once you see that there's a
relationship between you and the
transcendent,
let's say you start to take that
seriously and you can,
you can,
you can become inflated by that
prophetic duty,
let's say,
and and that's,
and that's a very dangerous.
He actually writes this like 20 pages
further,
use this for the great psych danger,
which always is always connected with
individuation lies in the identification
of ego consciousness with the self is
produced inflammation,
which Trenton,
which threatens conscience consciousness
is illusion.
Yes.
And he wrote a great essay,
a great essay called relations between
the ego and the unconscious,
which is completely unconscious,
incomprehensible unless you know the
background that we're discussing where
he wasn't very carefully that you have
to stay in the proper relationship to
the self,
right?
If the self overtakes the,
the,
the ego,
then that's a descent into like manic
religious insanity.
That ones has to be struck where there's
a relationship with the transcendent,
but there's also still the grounding in
the particular stuff here and now you
see this echoed this idea equity.
Interestingly enough,
in the superhero mythology that
dominated the adolescents imagination in
20th century,
every superhero,
so imagine the superhero.
It's like a partial manifestation of the
redemptive archetype.
Every superhero has to have an alter
ego.
And the alter ego well for Superman is
Clark camp,
mild mannered reporter and for
Spiderman,
it's,
you know,
high school,
troubled high school,
cause I nerd.
But what's so interesting about those
stories is that they understand without
the alter ego,
there's no superhero that both of those
have to exist at the same time,
the limitations and the end,
the transcendence of the limitations
have to both be there at that terrible
paradoxical juxtaposition
because the character isn't.
The character can't exist without that
tension.
And I think that that's.
Well,
that motif wouldn't recur continually
unless there was something to it that
was narratively precise and accurate.
There's something in this paragraph that
I want to tie it together when our
previous stuff,
because you talks about the end stage of
individuation as a coming together with
the immortal.
It goes with the immortal.
Now Joseph Campbell Campbell does
exactly the same.
He says,
the Christ in you doesn't die.
The Christ and you survived the death
and resurrection and use that in our
last talk.
When you close your,
um,
you've never elaborated on the death of
socrates and how he died in truth and
honor.
And then you said that part of the
spirit doesn't die.
So there is this theme of
these people are somehow connected with
something that is immortal and eternal,
could not be understood simply as they
have
established a relationship with an
archetypal mode of being that is eternal
and that continues to exist beyond them
and before them,
but they've,
they've established a relationship with
that.
Is that what that,
what he means by,
by the immortal?
Yes.
That,
that is what's meant.
Is that right?
It's that.
It's the turtle pattern.
It's theater.
It's like you're the eternal music and
the music goes on.
Even if you depart the scene,
the Christian is a Christian insistence
so that that I also wouldn't overlook
which is that also characterized as the
finite,
right?
That's the promise of the resurrection.
The resurrection of the body is that the
Christians insists that about
transcendent factor exists and that's
the Christ.
That's the word that's there at the
beginning of time and at the end of time
as as the judging revelation,
write this transcendent locals that's
eternal,
but that's no more valuable in some
sense.
Then the particular
creature that's that's,
that's subject to apparent,
apparent permanent death and it's very
difficult for modern people to grant the
idea of the bodily resurrection any
credence and
it's not something of which anyone can
speak.
I believe with any degree of
what would you say it,
knowing the Oregon consort or something
like that,
but at the same token,
the world is a very strange place and it
isn't obvious to me that
I've learned to.
I've learned to be very cautious in
Housley dismissing deep and ancient
ideas regardless of their strangeness,
and I do think that.
See,
the thing that's so interesting about
that Christian insistence is that it
valorizes the particular unbelievably
important because you could say,
well,
if it's merely a matter of the eternal
and the particular doesn't matter,
but then if the particular doesn't
matter,
you ended up with that kind of
nihilistic Buddhism,
the suffering that characterizes or even
in the proclivity for Christianity to
degenerate into the forums that Nisha
criticized,
which is well,
when you chase everything,
we do an eternal beyond.
It justifies everything terrible that's
happening on earth as trivial and
insignificant.
That relieves you of your moral
responsibility for,
for addressing it.
You can't,
at the very minimum,
the idea that the body is resurrected
valorization of the value of the
particular here and now,
and an emphasis on the fact that that
has defined value as well.
It needs to be attended to and cared for
properly.
At minimum it stopped.
It's
just one.
One thing,
uh,
under paragraph I want to reflect on.
It's the when you sense that
individuation is a,
could be a moment of deadliest apparel.
And then he refers to the tightrope
walker from now.
What this means is that it can be so the
danger can be so great when you embark
on individuation in almost by definition
means that the lesser you,
unless they're part of your soul and
your soul as to die,
and then I think I've been there and in
my own life,
and
that requires violence and recovery is
by no means guaranteed,
right?
That's exactly.
Well,
that's why.
That's why that Motif,
that's the Motif of going into the
abyss,
to to,
to rescue your father like it's an
abyss.
There's no guarantee that you'll emerge
from it.
It's a real.
It's genuine peril.
Now the you know the,
the,
the what you need to be armed with in
some sense to face.
That is the willingness to die,
that faith in rebirth,
the,
the willingness as well,
or the decision to start abide by the
truth
because in a moment of great peril,
this is another thing that.
This is one of the things I think that
terrified me into
attempting to abide by the truth to the
degree that I've been able to manage
this.
See,
I started to understand not least by
reading young that there were some
points in my life where I needed to rely
on my own judgment that I would be in a
particular situation that no one could
advise me about because no one would
have access to the information about the
particularities of my situation that I
would have
and that I can call on
my relationship with the eternal,
let's say to some degree.
But if I had worked and corrupted my own
judgment
when,
when the necessity for a decision
emerge,
I would make the wrong decision and then
I'd be lost.
What stood out to me the few times you
talked about this in a few lectures,
like as a sidetrack,
you talked about the death of the soul
and what,
what stood out to me is that you did
this in a very,
very efficient route when you really
felt.
It seemed to me like you felt the
gravity of it.
And um,
and then when you kind of laid out your
own story that you had to stop drinking,
stop smoking,
do to,
to focus more on your work
intuitively.
There was to,
it was a kind of a disparity between how
visceral you could talk about the death
of the soul and what you described as,
what that meant for you,
which I interpreted as mainly changing
your lifestyle a little and,
uh,
and,
and focus on your studies.
So the question would be why?
Why,
why do you think I saw the disparity and
if the disparities in the there,
how is it that you can talk about the
death of the soul,
which such figures?
Well,
I think I do think that there are things
that are worse than death.
I think that psychological
disintegration might be worse than death
because it can go on for so long and it
can be so incredibly painful.
To your point about communists,
communists is correct.
Is that the state that he exists in is
worse than death.
It's hell
now.
The disparity.
I'm not sure exactly what you meant by
that
meant
you talk with such vigor and then start
your fist.
We're awake about the death of the soul.
And then when you talked about letting
parts of yourself die,
you said it was mainly,
it was stopped drinking and stopped
smoking.
Zero responsibility I would say needs to
some degree is the letting go of that
because I had to make a choice between
something approximating gratifying,
immediate pleasure seeking and hyper
social or hyper social way of Ba now
that wasn't sustainable and in many ways
for obvious reasons and doing,
doing the difficult intellectual work
already had decided to embark on and
that was a death of a previous
personality.
It is trivial in some sense because
it's.
It's,
it's burning off that which obviously
needs to be burned off.
But I would also say by the same token,
that that doesn't make it a straight
forward process.
You alluded to this,
you know,
you said that you underwent a similar
set of experiences where the old parts
of you had to die.
It's like,
well that's
sub optimal and immature as they are.
First of all,
NGOs are still parts that are alive and
still and still an element of your
beginning.
They might even be parts that you love
and that other people love,
and there are certainly things that
you're familiar with,
their modes of being that you're
familiar with it.
It's a major sacrifice to live elements
of your personality.
It's also a proper sacrifice.
It was not an indictment on your report.
I understand that.
See,
the problem with the identity politics
types as far as I'm concerned,
is the proclivity is always to sacrifice
someone else feel oppressive and it's
always externalized the oppressor,
but in the individuation process,
you're the oppressor.
You are the oppressor,
but it's much.
See,
and this is also the problem,
this is something I really came to
understand what I was writing the
forward for.
The new version of social gets in school
like archipelago was.
What's the problem here?
Well,
something has to be sacrificed and put
the world right.
Well who,
what,
who or what is going to be sacrificed,
but you better make the proper
sacrifices established the right
relationship with the transcendent.
Well,
let's identify the evil as something
external to us and sacrifice that well.
What does that mean?
Well,
what it meant in the Russian revolution
was that everyone died,
but more specifically,
everyone was killed.
They were made into a burnt offering
to God and it was inappropriate.
It's like,
what if you're going to sacrifice
because you have to sacrifice yourself,
right?
That's the.
That's the crucifixion metaphor and
sacrifices.
You allow those parts of you that are
unworthy to die.
You encourage them to die even and,
and,
but we don't want to be foolish to say
that that's merely a matter of pursuing
your bliss,
let's say,
in,
in the,
in the Joseph Campbell manner or in
maybe in the city.
I mean,
that's being a bit hard on Campbell,
but it was an unfortunate phrase.
Yeah,
because if he knew better because he
knew about the journey into the abyss,
the sacrifice is,
even if it's partial,
it's still a depth.
I think also that this is why the death
and rebirth,
rebirth theme resonates so immediately
in,
in popular culture and in literature.
For example,
Gandalf who fell into the underworld,
the bell rock and then emerged as the
white.
Right,
and everyone's,
everyone's soul.
Well,
that's,
that's a,
that's a real representation of the
transfiguration of Moses Christ Gandalf,
the white,
so it's not like tolkien didn't know
these things and he knew these things
perfectly well.
That's right.
In such a relief.
I remember when I was a kid reading Lord
of the rings for the first time,
I was so appalled when gandalf
disappeared and so relieved when he
made,
when he was like,
oh no.
GANDALF's garden.
Like it's the death of God,
right?
What?
What are we going to do?
Open the great wizard.
This has disappeared.
Yeah.
And it is a terrible trial and you see
that with Gandalf's experiences in
underworld and he comes out white.
Well,
it's funny,
it comes up white white's interesting
because white is the sun,
then white is purity,
but why is also age,
you know,
and to undergo those experiences is also
to risk all the physiological
psychophysiological stress that widens
your beard and that,
that crazy your hair.
I'm going to tweet out now Jordan
Peterson says white is purity.
Yeah,
yeah.
Know the thing is you also see this in
more general popular culture.
Have you ever heard of Dragon Ball z?
No.
It was a cartoon.
It's an enemy and you have these
creatures.
They're called sayings,
and whenever they're warriors and
whenever they're in a fight with some
eternal enemy and the moment they're
about to die,
they can their their spirit and their
body can't take anymore.
They become super science,
which is the resurrect and they
transcend and their hair stands up and
it turns,
turns,
turns yellow,
and they get electricity all around
them.
So whenever they are about to die,
that's when they transcend.
So they have been completely destroyed
and that's when their transcendence
occurs.
In the beginning.
They can control it,
and that's a theme that keeps the entire
saga together is this continual
transcendence of the.
One of the themes that I developed in
maps of meaning is that there's ways of
construing yourself like you Construe
Yourself as who you are.
That's a stable state.
Let's say who you are right now.
That's me.
And then that all falls apart and then
you consider yourself as the chaos that
ensues when everything falls apart.
And that's a state of hopelessness.
And,
and then maybe you recovered from that
and you establish a new sense of order.
You say,
well,
I passed through the underworld and now
I'm in a better place and this is me,
this better place,
but then it's subject to fragmentation
as well,
and so what you learn is that you're not
the order no matter how compelling and
secure and promising that order is and
you're not the chaos that ensues when
that order is fragmented and you're not
even the reestablishment of new order.
You're the process by which that
transformation continually occurs and
that is the process of death and rebirth
and that's where you identified with is
that ever renewing process of death and
rebirth and that identification with
cracks that the Christians and the
Christian narrative is aiming at
instilling,
aiming to,
to the degree that something like that
aims.
So is this also the Nietzsche refers to
the man is a road between Beeston over
men.
I know that's not exactly the Christian
the delineation,
but instilled in more.
I think that's probably more associated
with the idea that we were talking about
earlier.
I mean these ideas are all late,
but I think that's more associated with
the idea of the partnership between man
and God,
mediated by conscious
man is that is that intermediary
finger because we're.
We're moving towards the idea,
but we're clearly not that that is a
tight rope lights because moving towards
the idealist,
precarious,
not the ideal and you can tumble at any
moment.
Seriousness to our being
psychically,
psychologically and spiritually as well
as physically it's well not.
That's part of aA.
turtle crucifixion as well as a constant
vulnerability of being a burden of being
human.
The necessary burden I suppose to me in
my more,
what would you call them?
I don't know.
You have these moments of thinking where
they're more metaphysical,
more metaphysical moments I suppose.
I do see that go on in there and engaged
in a partnership to bring about the
Kingdom of God on earth.
Something like that.
That there's something about that story.
That's exactly right.
That we should be struggling up yield
with our burdens towards the highest
possible ideal,
and if there's something about that
that's true or at least it's more true
than anything else we can conceive of.
And so that's the great adventure of
lights.
That's what you want to be cold too.
I think you are called to that by your
conscience,
I think.
Refer we we've talked for about 90
minutes now.
I think this is a good time to.
Yeah.
This is a great note to close off on.